[Music]
accessibility is an enabler
of rights autonomy and equality
accessibility is especially important
for persons with disabilities
so that they can fully participate to
all areas of life
on an equal basis with others cities
across the eu
are leading the way in creating more
accessible living
spaces and making life easier for
persons with disabilities
with the eu access city award we reward
these efforts and make them more visible
it also reminds us that we all have a
responsibility to make europe
fully accessible this is why
accessibility is one of the priorities
in the eu's new strategy
for the rights of persons with
disabilities
presented this march this year we also
celebrate the european year of rail
we will showcase those cities that have
made visible efforts to make their train
stations
accessible for all so i invite you to
apply to the access city award
2022 who will succeed
your shopping and be the 12th winner of
the access
city award let's find out in december
you